but this idea this idea that you haven't
in the wire story is is you know one of
the simplest data points right it's very
basic it's just dollars and cents just
trying to make that piece of data that
one piece of data transparent to people
and I I'm i wonder if you think that
that that simplicity is is kind of
whether it is is deceiving and how
simplicity and how simple or apparently
simple it might be if that in fact more
complicated problems you think then then
drug delivery or some of these research
questions if I get a bill that says we
charge you 100 thousand dollars but
since you are a very nice guy you look
good in your blue shirt or maybe I don't
give you a reason I give you a 95 90
thousand dollar relief so you are you
owe me ten thousand dollars you have no
idea what happened but if you got 90
sort of drivers you that are run down
the street and inside everybody who has
got ninety thousand dollars that they
saw the old and invite them to the
barricades it will be lonely so what'd
you do wrong and that's frog enable the
continuation of the economic behavior of
this industry